[Musik]
geheimnisvoller kreml
kaum jemandem gelingt es hinter seinen
mauern zu blicken
ich möchte ergründen wie die menschen in
russland leben jetzt zur zeit der
ukraine krise auf dem land und in der
stadt
zwei auslandschweizer helfen mir dabei
sie kennen sich hier aus jetzt glück
dass sie ihr ziel wenn sie holt die
offense brot die russische nachrichten
verfolge ich irgendwie irgendwo ihre mit
die für den bericht bestätigen
zwar hält sie der bauer hans michel aus
dem berner oberland ist ein alter
bekannter
er lebt seit zehn jahren in der
russischen provinz
[Musik]
200 kilometer entfernt in moskau
ermöglicht mir der schreinermeister york
tus einblicke in die welt der
superreichen
[Musik]
der luzerner lebt schon 18 jahre in
russland
er besitzt eine baufirma und er
unterstützt mit einer schweizer stiftung
russische bedürftige
[Musik]
ich tauche ein in eine welt voller
überraschungen und irritationen
[Musik]
vergesst das ist ja wie sie die
verfolgergruppe aus dem nachbardorf
rostow ja ich sag das katastrophen ist
echt du warst aber eine aber wunderbare
stimme lieder sehr melancholisch ein
schwerer brocken mit ihrer lebensfreude
[Musik]
wie jeden sommer ist eine gruppe von
schweizer bauern zu besuch bei hans
michel und seiner frau julia auch hans
michel ernte russland auf einer solchen
gruppenreise kennen der free fire und
wanderte aus der schweiz erlebt es
offenbar ist der große grill linie genau
glücklich sie hier
[Musik]
normal ist nicht überheblich mitmach mit
einer liste zusammen schafft es der
hesse hier absolut keine probleme
das dürfen wir die ideale zeit in schwyz
cilic vor und ich habe viel besser so
jetzt die ganze ukraine krise sie
befehlen
ich lernte hans michael 2005 kennen
damals filmten wir zum ersten mal auf
den betrieb schweizer milch nun bin ich
gespannt wie es ihm heute geht und wie
er zurechtkommt in putins russland
doch der reihe nach
das russische abenteuer von hans-michael
begann im berner oberland
er war bekannt als einer der besten
züchter haus und hof hatte er von seinem
vater übernommen und das meiste land
gepachtet
insgesamt zwölf hektar wovon die zahl
von 750 euro und etwas länger gebiet
hinter 380 oder links verrückter bahn
fordert ein schwarzes tier liegt der
tonne hektar und weil mir nicht
vorstellen ich noch 25 jahre hier warten
bis die pension über hunger hat nicht
frustriert
und so kam es dass hans michel 2004 mit
zwei schweizer kollegen diesen milch
wirtschaftsbetrieb kaufte und nach
russland auswanderte
150000 franken legte jeder damals auf
den tisch den rest finanzierten sie mit
einem bundes kredit wir filmten jakob
sepp und hans ein jahr nach ihrer
ankunft in der region kaluga 200
kilometer südlich von moskau
sie rufen trend zurück und ein haufen
neuer probleme ihr betrieb war
ursprünglich teil einer riesigen
kolchose viele ehemalige sowjetische
großbetriebe gingen nach der wende
konkurs auch hier waren die meisten
maschinen defekt alles lag am boden
die drei pioniere aber ließen sich nicht
unterkriegen
als erstes sollten sie einen kuhstall
und ein gästehaus
immer wieder aber hatten sie mühe mit
der mentalität der angestellten
direktoren auf ihrem gebiet bringen dass
man im prinzip einfach habe drei
zivilisten besser erledigt werden ohne
dass er darauf ziehen
schon bald aber zeigte sich russland
hans michel auch von seiner schönsten
seite
mit seiner neuen liebe julia besuchte er
das sommerfest im nachbarstädtchen der
wacker war julia hatte schon ein
töchterchen aus erster ehe bastian goß
friendlyway duft klar und einfach zu
einer familie hin zur es geht also
weniger schnickschnack hatte mein mann
wird sagen das ist einfach ein bier
damals arbeitete julia in der
milchverarbeitung des betriebs es war
ein schock
bei uns sind die chefs die chefs sie
sitzen im büro und sagen wo es lang geht
sie aber sitzen bis mitternacht ständig
auf dem traktor ohne pause und nehmen
nur ein kleines picknick
sie tun mir richtig leid
[Musik]
doch es blieb ein kurzer traum den sie
zu dritt träumten
2008 trennten sie sich
nur hans glaubte unerschütterlich an das
russische abenteuer herbst 2014
erntezeit auf dem betrieb schweizer
milch die russische landwirtschaft ist
noch immer wenig effizient und stark von
importen abhängig
doch jetzt sagt der kreml die ukraine
krise sei eine chance russland könne und
müsse sich selbst ernähren
putin hat ein importverbot für
agrargüter verhängt und höhere
subventionen versprochen hans michel ist
skeptisch
zehn jahre lebt der berner oberländer
nun in der region kaluga
inzwischen ist er direktor des betriebs
schweizer milch er hat zwei neue
schweizer partner und 45 angestellte
heute will mir der gelernte
meisterlandwirt sein reich zeigen
für die ernte hat er zusätzliche
arbeiter angestellt mit ihren
landmaschinen
ich hatte schon angst du seite ausgebuht
werdet ihr heute nicht fertig reicht es
nicht schade also kein freier tag zu
hause
[Musik]
der betrieb schweizer milch produziert
fast das ganze futter für seine kühe und
rinder selbst
nicht überall ist die ernte so gut wie
hier
jetzt letzter missbraucht wird
dann kam recker was noch gar jetzt
kriegen wir schon so als ich also hier
die regierung kohl
peschel hinter machen die weschnitz
natürlich excel ja damals verloren geht
auf der anderen seite immer russland so
flach dass sie das netz schon bedeutende
mengen wurden vorverlegt
fast denkt bauer hans schon wie ein
echter rose
seinen traum von unendlichen weiten und
unbegrenzten möglichkeiten konnte er
hier verwirklichen
[Musik]
hier sind wir gerade mache also passiv
sektor mobil ist eine grenze durch
global das nochmals hoffen wir papiere
kapllani zeichnerisch majesty 2 hector
dahinter sie 20 hektar rund 50 hektar
raps vor straßenrand neues tristar nach
ute betrieb um auch im betrieb ist eine
festliche land wo ist also insgesamt mit
dem hier 800 hektaren also 40 mal mehr
land als ein durchschnittlicher
schweizer bauer besitzt
[Musik]
knapp die hälfte der 800 hektar gehört
dem betrieb schweizer milch der rest ist
pachtland ausländer dürfen nur 49
prozent ihres landwirtschafts bodens
besitzen
[Musik]
400 russische schwarz fleck kühe und 300
kälber und rinder alle selbst gezüchtet
die milch verkauft sich gut bis in die
moskauer supermärkte
mich beeindruckt wie der betrieb trotz
vieler schwierigkeiten gewachsen ist
[Musik]
falls möglich
rolf von felten millionen für die
zukunft ganz zuchtbetrieb richtige
winter verkaufen
das vitra betriebszweig wer war diese
verbessern womit grundlage sieht also
man mir die chance nummer nutzen
[Musik]
am nächsten tag führt uns hans-michael
zu seinem nachbarn einem alten freund
ein weiterer schweizer der in russland
sein glück gesucht hat
nach zwei stunden fahrt kommen wir tief
im wald in einer märchenwelt an
auf dem kleinen bio hof von georg tus
zwiebel dass die küsten mit über 100
sprit so baut jetzt die letzte für
bewusste sehen und dahin nur drüber lose
gott werden elektroniker und dort zurück
noch hat der beruf ist vorläufig nur ein
hobby von jörg tus der diplomierte
schreinermeister und holz ingenieur
besitzt eine große baufirma in moskau
zudem hat er im gebiet kaluga eine
schweizer stiftung mitbegründet wenn
dieser pakt mit den fahrgästen
cinematics leistungsseite es also es
fast 4
das ist das kann ihm also sicher die
spontaneität der die fröhlichkeit
das ist die art haben wir nicht immer
vor der russische seele
aber die jetzt umschrieben das gesamt
der hintergrund wenn jetzt wie vor
menschen nur die russische sprache die
russische literatur ist das zu hoch
halte seine liebe zu russland hat aber
noch eine andere seite
natalia auch jörg tauss hat eine
russische freundin gefunden
sie ist eigentlich gerichtsmedizinerin
hilft ihm nun aber auf seinem bauhof
die beiden haben einen haus
lieferservice für reiche kunden in
moskau aufgezogen
eine vielversprechende marktlücke einmal
sagte mir ein gast pro kunde
du musst die eier nicht waschen so weiß
ich dass sie wirklich vom land kommen um
nicht auf seinem laden als wir uns
kennenlernten sah ich in ihm nur den
ausländern
ich dachte die ausländer seien
unseriöser männer
nachdem wir uns näher kennengelernt
hatten merkte ich dass er über sehr gute
qualitäten verfügt
er ist ein guter mensch sehr hilfsbereit
großzügig er kann gut reden kümmert sich
um alles er gefällt mir ich liebe ihn
mit der schweizer stiftung radio gar
deutsch regenbogen unterstützt jörg
notleidende menschen in den dörfern der
umgebung die der russische staat
vernachlässigt wie valentina
schewtschenko sie kann sich von ihrer
rente von 150 franken kaum ernähren hat
kein geld für den gasleitungen anschluss
keins für brennholz
hier aber wird es kalt im winter minus
20 grad
das ist gutes holz bürkl
das wird sie wärmen was filme niveau
zeigen sie dass in der schweiz
wir wollen zeigen wie wir hier sind nein
dass die einen holz haben die anderen
nicht dass man einander helfen kann
jörg tus nimmt mich mit nacht arosa ein
städtchen im gebiet kaluga knapp zwei
stunden von seiner bio hof entfernt an
einem nebenfluss der wolga es macht
einen schmucken eindruck
kein vergleich sagt jörg zuvor ein paar
jahren
er besitzt hier eine wohnung gleich
neben der schweizer stiftung radio gar
diese ist unabhängig arbeitet zurzeit
aber mit den lokalen behörden zusammen
denn es herrscht hochbetrieb
mit flüchtlingen aus der ukraine hallo
wie geht's was gestern auf dem amt wir
sind eigentlich vergebens hingefahren
die dokumente waren nicht fertig wir
sollen in einer woche wiederkommen
was sind das für dokumente die
provisorische bescheinigung von unserem
flüchtlingsstatus damit können wir uns
dann im gebiet kaluga bewegen und sind
den russischen bürgern rechtmäßig
gleichgestellt hunderte ukraine
flüchtlinge brauchen in und um terrasse
ein dach über dem kopf
wie die lehrerin julia encke und der
mechaniker anton tschechow sie sind vor
kurzem aus der ost ukraine geflohen und
nun vorübergehend im haus der stiftung
untergebracht in russland gibt es für
die ausbildung unseres kindes mehr
perspektiven der bildungsstand in der
ukraine ist sehr tief hier können wir
auch eine eigene wohnung finden
unser haus in der ukraine hat während
der kampfhandlungen schaden genommen
in russland ist es viel einfacher für
eine wohnung zu sparen
mit den löhnen im donbass und der
ukraine war es unmöglich geld auf die
seite zu legen den ukrainischen eltern
der kleinen varvara erscheint russland
als das gelobte land
ein stockwerk tiefer für ihr treffen
haben sich diese damen herausgeputzt es
sind ehrenamtliche helferin das
allmonatliche kränzchen ist ein
highlight in ihrem alltag und ein
dankeschön für ihre arbeit
wenn immer es geht ist stiftungsrat jörg
mit dabei war
minute führen dass ich nicht ob sie
junge burschen ablagen der tag an dem
sie die chancen sind minimal und mini
motivation hütte maria darüber wie hüte
zu probieren
die frauen erzählen mir was sie in ihrem
leben alles durchgemacht haben
weltkrieg kalter krieg perestroika und
wie sie danach erschreckt am abgrund
standen weil niemand ihnen sagte wie es
weitergehen sollte als putin präsident
wurde
ich kriege richtig gänsehaut da fühlte
sich unser volk wieder mehr geachtet
dass ich nicht mehr für sein land und
hatte auch keine angst mehr um 98
prozent jener menschen die den weltkrieg
und die ganze misere bei uns überlebt
sind bereit ihr leben für putin
herzugeben er dass er die kindergärten
verbessert und sich um die gesundheit
der kinder kümmert das verstehen alle
nicht nur die eltern und jetzt kümmert
er sich auch noch um die studenten
verstehen sie das gibt uns einen solchen
glauben an unsere zukunft mit ihm aber
wir haben auch große angst dass ihm um
gottes willen nichts passiert ich weiß
nicht ob sie noch fragen haben zeigen
sie die tischrunde sie weinen alle wir
sind wieder stolz auf unser vaterland
und alles mann soll dort im westen nicht
schlecht über und sprechen sie sagen
dort ja so manches was nicht stimmt wir
sind doch dagegen wie können wir denn
gegen die ukraine kann niemals wir leben
sie doch wir können sie ja nur
unterstützen ihnen helfen und schmerz
das so sehr dass jede familie von uns
hat ja verwandte in der ukraine
wir können auf keinen fall krieg führen
was immer man über uns sagt
[Musik]
frühmorgens auf dem betrieb schweizer
milch heute herrscht hier große
aufregung
julia und hans michel haben 2006
geheiratet
sie haben einen sohn johann
ein wichtiges ereignis steht bevor
johanns erster schultag in ganz russland
wird dieser tag traditionell gefeiert
im anzug heute bringe ich meinen sohn in
die erste klasse
[Musik]
hans wollte ihn schon mit 61 schulen
aber ich wollte dass er noch ein wenig
spielen darf die schule kann warten
die kindheit vergeht ja so schnell auch
nastia julias tochter aus erster ehe ist
mit dabei
[Musik]
die fahrt zum schulhaus im kleinen
nachbarstädtchen da wacker war dauert
rund 20 minuten
[Musik]
manches hat sich verändert seit ich das
erste mal hier war vor knapp zehn jahren
so viele und so neue autos gab es damals
nicht
kein wunder sagt man mir immer wieder
den russen ging es noch nie so gut wie
heute
jetzt musste dann viele aufgaben machen
aber nicht am samstag und sonntag
samstag und sonntag nicht aber sonst
schon
auch inter wacker war dieser tag höchst
feierlich begangen
jedes kind bringt seiner lehrerin einen
blumenstrauß johanns einschulung mit
hans ans herz in der schweiz hätte er
sich das alles nicht vorstellen können
[Musik]
jena schau nach hinten die kamera
700 kinder und jugendliche aus den
dörfern rund um kawakawa gehen hier zur
schule von der ersten bis zur elften
klasse
das aufwand von hohem niveau besetzt es
auf der starterliste mit allgemeiner
bildung klaut
[Musik]
juni vor
so harmonierte nicht fixiert wurde aber
kalt
[Musik]
mit solchen gedanken steht hans michel
an diesem tag in das alleine da
einmarsch der erstklässler ein großer
moment und höchst patriotischer sowie
putin es haben will
[Musik]
einige jahre das ist sicher wird johann
der kleine russe mit wurzeln im berner
oberland nun hier zur schule gehen
[Musik]
eigentlich wäre es hier fast
paradiesisch wären da nicht die
schreckensbilder aus der ukraine die das
russische fernsehen täglich verbreitet
ich will wissen wie sich die krise auf
den betrieb schweizer milch auswirkt
das teilt jetzt die tiere warten
lattenschuss startete die hier keine
anträge 60 nachfrage schritt hatte die
hier jetzt so groß exportieren und wie
frattini der gewählte kontaktstelle es
ist schade dass die osteuropäer passiert
weg ist die kurze und stammende versucht
etwas allerdings ist neu putins
importstopp hat die nachfrage nach
einheimischer milch steigen lassen
für direktor hans aber ist klar er will
davon nicht profitieren
das ist auch nicht nötig er hat heute
weit weniger schlaflose nächte als
früher
der betriebs umsatz stieg in den letzten
jahren stetig 2013 auf über zwei
millionen euro unter hof hat fast keine
schweizer schulden mehr nur noch kleine
russische kredite der
bürokratiedschungel hat sich allerdings
nicht gelichtet und auch die korruption
ist nicht besiegt das braucht leute mit
durchblick
man konnte mir ein betrieb mit schweizer
lizenz die ganze umweltschutz bestehen
jetzt schon für deutsche sprache aber
wieder auf russische das lesen der
verstand nicht aus noch mal nur auf
service
was aber halten die jungen buchhalterin
von präsident putin und der politischen
lage es wird einen bewaffneten konflikt
geben ihn etwa 23 jahren ganz bestimmt
und nicht unbedingt mit der ukraine da
gibt es manche andere varianten nun
russland anzugreifen um russland in
einen bewaffneten konflikt
hineinzuziehen
wer will das denn wer das spiel
ich bin mir ganz sicher amerika will
russland in einen krieg hineinziehen um
russland zu schwächen wir denken immer
nur gut über putin
er ist ein sehr starker mensch ein
leader der russland aus dem chaos
geführt hat und der fähig ist russlands
platz zuvorderst auf unserem planeten zu
halten so hoffen wir
[Musik]
und hans michel der nun schon zehn jahre
hier lebt was denkt er über die krise
noch über andere thema diskutiert
schlechte straßen schlechte schulungs
bild zdf awo vertrauen in spitalpflege
system maxi und über die heikle die
falschen immer diskutiert sondern
einfach wieder da sollte man gut sohnes
x länge oder hurra hurra die mit ihrer
natürlich vorkommen und mit dem
auftreten von putin hält man sich wieder
als spieler von américa als gewalt
machte positioniert weil lange zweifache
deutschland tour
jetzt sollen wieder auf einer ist
erfüllt mit stadt sollte mit
nationalstolz
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
was belastet hier den konflikt
persönlich am meisten das land wo ende
dank konflikte der tour integriert
das ist enkel tigers vorbelastet ist die
vorstellung dass er jetzt irgendwo
sekunde wird dass das sehr lange bis der
lithos verlassen ankäufe seit der
annexion der krim stehen laut neuen
umfragen über 80 prozent der russischen
bevölkerung hinter putin das
staatsfernsehen mit seiner propaganda
ist für sie die wichtigste und oft
einzige informationsquelle die
berichterstattung erlebe ich als
unerträglich einseitig
[Musik]
aber nach all den gesprächen beginne ich
meine eigene sicht und jene unserer
medien zu hinterfragen
[Musik]
immer mehr wird mir bewusst dass auch
das schwergewicht unserer
berichterstattung aus einer bestimmten
perspektive erfolgt und geprägt ist von
unserem westlichen werten und interessen
[Musik]
wie ist die stimmungslage bei der elite
in moskau jörg tauss will mir einen
zugang ermöglichen zur abgehobenen geld
seiner kunden der superreichen
vor zehn jahren baute er hier eine
baufirma auf ein generalunternehmen für
innenausbau anfänglich um arbeitslosen
jugendlichen aus davos seinen job zu
reden
seine firma profitiert vom gegenwärtigen
bauboom in spitzenzeiten beschäftigt er
gegen 100 angestellte
der stürmer
bis morgen
wir natürlich schon länger in russland
und vor rund acht jahren ja etwas glück
zur richtigen zeit am richtigen ort die
richtig gut kennen trauen sich die
russischen ist sehr gute dienste
erwiesen
und noch einen ist das schritt für
schritt ist das wieder gegangen und so
weiter entwickelt wir sind an der grenze
zu einem job exklusiven raich beim
eingangstor müssen wir den pass zeigen
ein wohngebiet hinter gitter zäunen am
rand von moskau putin wohnt gleich um
die ecke
irgendwo anhalten und aussteigen ist uns
in diesem gelände nicht erlaubt
[Musik]
pro monat die liebesbriefe jetzt wo das
ist für die meistens zweitrangig was am
wochenende dass die lügt die lava jeden
regenwald in die eigene zone das ist
eigentlich das ist eine eigene
gesellschaft wieder eine vermischung von
der unsere gesellschaft zu der oper
findet items in deutschland er nimmt uns
mit auf eine baustelle
[Musik]
bei diesem objekt ist der schweizer nur
für die fenster zuständig
[Musik]
allein diese kosten über eine million
euro
6000 quadratmeter reine wohnfläche wer
hier in solchen anwesen wohnt gehört zur
politischen oder business elite
russlands arbeitet zuoberst in der öl-
gas- oder metall branche
der swimmingpool mit whirlpool später
mit goldenem anstrich darf da nicht
fehlen
daher immer ziemlich projekt das sind
denn also das sind die maler schlosser
das ist das ist ein wilder diese tussi
quadratmeter groß da ist unter die für
kühlung und oder verarbeitet wurde nicht
also dass ich kann mir schon vorstellen
wie das drinnen ausgesehen
also der hunte hätte kein großer
sicherheitsanspruch aber in der
garderobe schick rief recht der xl
wollten nicht dass er nackt erschossen
das interview soll ihnen wo sie halt da
ist die hier wirklich die heutige
wilhelmine sicherheits auswirkt werden
die sagen immer gesagt dass uns franck
einem seitenfach schon zum termin ist
die devise also sohnes gesamthaft dass
wir um die 300 bis 400 millionen euro
dass sie ein künstlicher see in dieser
parklandschaft für auserwählte
immerhin führt wirtschaft ist so gut es
geht an daten immer sofort wird also xls
dem müden negativ und wenn real sind
geht die möglichkeit dass man die
tätigkeit dann auch eine video den
heimstarken die welt der oligarchen
noch stehen sie hinter putin doch seit
der ukraine krise hat eine massive
kapitalflucht aus russland eingesetzt
die den präsidenten zu einem aggressiven
kurs fragt was sie so drauf vorhanden
würde jetzt so nieder unterschrieb also
es ist ein anderes ist sich ein anderer
demokratie ist dass die die schweiz
stellt wieder ganz andere beziehung dazu
hat man in russland alters sind von der
stadt geführt werden uns prozent sind
für die jetzige präsident und ich meine
die elite schon länger dauern russland
sind die schöne da oben steht ist
wichtig schon jetzt ist die stabilität
wo alle russland mir genügend deflation
kam war ich stets anders als man noch
miterlebt hat und im moment der letzte
ist seit 14 jahren an der macht ist
stabilität und darum laufen möchten
wissen für die dem land und darum dass
sie könne jeder der fragen auf der
straße also sich anwachsen wird euch
begrüßen
[Musik]
und tatsächlich die stadt entwickelt
sich atemberaubend vor knapp zehn jahren
stand moscow city noch nicht
[Musik]
doch im dezember 2014 gut zwei monate
nach dem gespräch mit jörg tus ist die
stabilität der wirtschaft gefährdet
der rubel verliert an wert
die hälfte aller staatseinnahmen kommt
aus dem öl und gasgeschäft die
erdölpreise aber fand
die folgen der west sanktionen sind
nicht absehbar
und westliche investoren bleiben immer
mehr aus weil sie das vertrauen in
präsident putin verloren haben
[Musik]
es könnte breite bevölkerungskreise
empfindlich treffen
nicht nur die elite
auch die neue mittelschicht
vielen menschen geht es besser denn je
wenigstens vorläufig noch kein wunder
stellen sie präsident ihn nicht in frage
[Musik]
russland ohne putin
wir sind die macht zufällig geraten wir
ende september in die erste große
protestaktion seit ausbruch des ukraine
konflikt von gegen 40.000 menschen ist
die rede
ich bin froh sie zu sehen es gibt sie
also doch einige wenige in dem
riesenland die von einer
zivilgesellschaft träumen andere wie
jede hoffnung auf demokratie verloren
haben verlassen russland über 200.000
waren es 2014
mehr als je zuvor vor allem akademiker
bei all meiner skepsis gegenüber
potenzieller politik nach all den
widersprüchlichen eindrücken auf dieser
reise glaube ich das heutige russland
etwas besser zu verstehen
wir sind wieder auf dem kleinen
bauernhof von jörg tus 200 kilometer von
moskau entfernt sein glück scheint ihr
gefunden zu haben obwohl er in seinen
langen russland jahren schon manche
talfahrt miterlebt hat seinen hof hat er
nicht zuletzt aufgebaut um allfälligen
währungs stürzen als selbstversorger
trotzen zu können
auch die ukraine krise trägt er mit
fassung
also markt eine krise sichere option
zurückzog das internet ist nicht tot
schaffe ich sehe kein grund das mail
marketing ist nicht sozial abbrechen und
wieder zurück ins schwitzen und x1 ihre
zukunft als mini zukunft ist dass
mehrere weiterhin der bruderhofer
zusammen mit der natalia und wer weiß
also ich kann mir vorstellen sichtbare
holländern das auch gut läuft dass
vielleicht etwas neues projekt wieder zu
machen
[Musik]
mit beiden händen habe auch hans michel
seine chancen in russland gepackt und
wurzeln geschlagen
[Musik]
jetzt ist feierabend ein seltener
ruhiger moment für die ganze familie
wir machen relative die zukunft keine
großen gedanken
hier haben ist schweiz neu hätte sie
denke die mit der familie schwitzkasten
auf der iss ablegen hat sogar die
schweiz geschickt ins bild vom klima
muss wasser lebensmittel holt das beste
schweizer schulgeld aber vor dem
geschenkekauf nein keinen tisch sie
fühle mich hier wohl das kurz unfall die
viele gute freunde schweizer und die
probleme kennedy würde mir menschlich
schweiz genauer betrag fordere
moralische rodeo drive gut finden was da
abgeht eine denke die jetzt hier bei
oder geschützte
[Musik]